أعتقد أنه سيكون فكرة
إيجابية للسوق أن
شخصية مثل الأصدقاء عبد العزيز
تأخذها مع كل تاريخ
أوبيك الذي لديه كما تعلمون محاولًا
خوض 24 منتجًا داخل أوبك وليس
جهاز أوبك.  ليس سهلاً ، يتطلب الأمر
شخصية معينة لا تفقد
زخمها أو قوتها مع إزالة
هوليدا هولي لا.
المنتجين
معًا وأنا أعتمد على أن هذه
الاستمرارية ستحدث
خاصة أن الأمير عبد الله يرى أن
على دراية كبيرة بالسوق
مؤثر جدًا في جميع القرارات
التي اتخذتها
المملكة من قبل. لقد أجريت هذه المحادثة
معك في ستة  أشهر هي أن تظل اتفاقية أوبك خارج أوبك
كما هي دون خالد
الفارلي الذي كان مهندس تلك
الاتفاقية ، أعتقد أن الاتفاقية
أكبر من طلبها جميعًا
كوزراء  التعهدات
والالتزام من جانب البلدان التي حققنا
فيها أربعة أسابيع من المكاسب في
أسعار الطاقة وتحوم حول 60 دولارًا للبرميل ،
ولكن هناك اعتقاد بأنه تم تقييده
بسبب المخاوف بشأن الركود العالمي
القادم من وجهة نظرك ،
هل ترى أي تباطؤ في  الطلبات التي
تشير إلى وجود ركود قادم في
قطاع الهيدروكربونات ، نرى أن الطلب
صحي ، الفكرة أو التأثير
من التوتر التجاري يؤثر على
الجميع ، ليس فقط النفط
والغاز الذي يؤثر في الأسواق القديمة
التي نأمل أن نراها  تقليل
التوتر بين الولايات المتحدة والصين ،
وهذا مع التقدير الجيد ، تعتبر الصين
زبونًا كبيرًا لك بالنسبة لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
من حيث الطاقة هنا ، فماذا ستقول
للولايات المتحدة والصين لأنها تواصل
العمل منذ شهور من وجهة نظرك
للحماية  النمو العالمي ، ما الذي
ترغب في رؤيته يحدث ، أعتقد أنه من
مصلحة الاقتصاد العالمي بما
في ذلك اقتصاداتهم التي يحتاجون إليها لتسوية
هذا النزاع التجاري بين ر.
تنحنح وانتهت بسرعة